thank you all for the invitation I guess
to lead off I will say I'm very much
looking forward to spending an entire
week here thinking about these issues
and challenges with people many of whom
are part of the Census team and I do
have a very big acknowledgement slide
but it's at the end rather than the
beginning and also others that I know
have thought hard about these problems
I'm not going to go to my first slide
I'm gonna say a few introductory remarks
the Census Bureau acknowledged in 2016
that database reconstruction was a
vulnerability of the methods used by the
Census Bureau I'm not gonna point
fingers than any other statistical
agency by the methods of the methods
used by the Census Bureau historically
for publishing products from censuses
surveys and other sources
that is in my view step one it's a
necessary condition to move from the ad
hoc world of disclosure limitation that
now it will point fingers all
statistical agencies have lived in for
quite some time basically since the
first mathematical theorems that
appeared in statistics ivan felides 1972
paper on subtraction attacks we've lived
in that world a long time we were
comfortable in that world because we
thought we understood the nature of the
problem and to be frank in the 1970s and
1980s we did pretty well understand the
nature of that problem we were going to
publish large bound volumes of tabular
summaries of data where the principal
source for those data was the
statistical agency and the competitive
sources outside the siskel agency were
at best rare and most often non-existent
in addition we were going to give the
scientific community direct the access
to the micro data records process
through disclosure limitation so that
more general hypotheses then could be
embodied in published tables might be
studied on the Census Bureau has been
releasing micro data products since 1960
I think you had the world's champion of
micro data products here last week Steve
Ruggles
who probably had a slightly different
view on the situation than you're going
to get from me it was really important
to acknowledge that the world has
changed that the concept of a small
group of statisticians locked in the
backroom doing statistical disclosure
limitation using methods that they were
sworn to keep secret against attackers
that were explicitly naive along
dimensions that we are happy to discuss
now that world has changed and it's
changed forever you can no longer
justify
using any kinds of models that make
arbitrary attacker assumptions and that
is at the heart of the sea change in the
way statistical agencies and not just
statistical agencies it's at the heart
of the sea change in which any curator
of confidential data thinks about what
is exposed to the public from those
confidential data that insight came
directly from computer science and in
particular from the cryptographic
approach to safety out of publication
that insight that you can't make
assumptions about the attacker that you
have to give the attacker enormous
computational resources so we'll just
say unlimited and arbitrary outside
information if you want to be able to
write down a mathematical guarantee of
what you can and cannot protect against
that insight is fundamental to the way
that the Census Bureau is trying to
transform its publication systems but it
has not been universally adopted and I'm
going to talk today about some of the
things that you need to think about
inside a large institution trying to
make a major modification in the way it
approaches the publication of its
products so
[Music]
running a census it's where the Census
Bureau gets its name you all know that
it's in article 1 section 2 maybe you
don't all know it's an article 1 section
2 of the US Constitution and while I
don't have that Clause here for you to
examine most people who see it don't get
past the every 10 years but the last
phrase of that clause is as they shall
by law direct article 1 is the
constitutional construction of the House
of Representatives in the Senate
Congress they is the Congress so the
census is meant to be conducted under
the statutory supervision of the
Congress and it is designed to collect
the data that underpin our democracy at
the very highest level reapportioning
the House of Representatives at the next
level by statute providing data to each
state to read it redraw every single
legislative district in the country but
that same statute contains a provision
that is actually it's a 1950s error
provision so it's an actually very very
strong statement about what constitutes
a privacy breach a privacy breach
according to that statute is publishing
anything in which the identity of the
supplier of that data item can be
inferred now there's no mathematical
language around that and it has always
been interpreted inside the Census
Bureau probabilistically meaning that
you make some risk assessments and then
you make some choices and you balance
the interests of publication against the
interests of privacy loss but until
formal methods for doing this came along
I know I'm being filmed but I'm going to
go ahead and say it there was a lot of
hand waving going on and that hand
waving is no longer useful so
basically what does it mean to
acknowledge the database reconstruction
vulnerability I'm not sure that quite a
few cryptographers in the audience would
necessarily agree with my prioritization
here but this is how I represent it when
I have to talk to more general audiences
the first lesson is straight from the
database reconstruction theorem you
can't publish too many statistics to
accurately you've got a finite
information budget and a finite
information budget gets exhausted with a
finite number of publications we'll see
later how many are still on the table
for the 2020 census it challenges the
word finite in that statement secondly
this comes straight from the original
differential privacy publication noise
infusion is a necessary condition to
guard against an informed attacker so if
we're going to get rid of the
assumptions about attackers then we have
to accept that noise diffusion is
necessary it's not a luxury it's not
something that you can necessarily even
specify to behave in the way that you
would like it to behave the randomness
that comes from noise infusion is a
necessary condition for developing
publication systems that protect against
arbitrary outside information that
really really is hard
finally the last one might not seem so
strange especially if you came from the
cryptographic background but kerckhoffs
principle applied to data publication
basically says that you're no longer
have to keep any of this secret there's
no advantage to keeping it secret and
there's a positive benefit from the
transparency that being public about the
algorithms and the parameter values and
the code bases you're going to see a
bunch of talks that's a technical term
today and through the rest of the week
by people working in collaboration with
the Census Bureau or in some cases
actually employees of the Census Bureau
we have a special category of employees
for academic collaborators all of that
mathematics is going into the public
domain and the code base is going into
the public domain the co basis for that
we used for the eighteen Indian test
which I'll show you some pictures of in
a few minutes that code base is going
into the public domain on March 28th we
might miss that deadline but we are
working hard not to and if we miss it we
won't miss it by more than a few days
all right
transparency really is a benefit all
right it took a while for us to complete
the internal experiments necessary to
put the nail in the coffin of
traditional methods for publishing
decennial censuses universe enumerations
I think there are actually some people
in the room who are among the ones I
consulted in late 2016 to say I I think
this is feasible but the set of people
who understand census data and the set
of people who understand database
reconstruction attacks doesn't have in
the intersection so can we create enough
intersection so that I can get a team at
the Census Bureau to do a real database
reconstruction attack the only reason
that I am NOT reporting detailed
scientific information from that is that
I've had these two slides cleared not
just by the Census Bureau but by some of
the target journals that we are going to
submit to I'm an economist I'm used to
operating in the open working paper
regime but that's not the regime that
we're operating in here so they will be
public but they will be already through
external peer review before they're made
public what I'm talking about today
isn't going to change very much so we
did a record level reconstruction of the
person data in the 2010 census that
means that we constructed a record for
all three hundred eight million seven
hundred five thousand five hundred
thirty-eight people went testifying in
the three trials that I had to testify
and finishing up on January 31st in
Maryland that number was used so many
times that I now say it's just as
trippingly as my colleagues who were
around when that number was finalized so
at one record for every single one v
publication variables the lock that the
person lived in if you're familiar with
census geography there were 11 million
blocks in the 2010 census 6.2 million of
them actually had people in them and we
didn't protect whether a block was
occupied or not so that's a public
number your sex your aging years your
race all sixty three categories that the
OMB classification permits the only one
that's not of not permitted is none of
the above if you actually left it blank
you got imputed it so there's a an
ethnicity Hispanic or not so just five
variables but one for every single
person in the US
we took the reconstructed micro data and
used fairly straightforward exact record
linkage techniques against for
commercial databases that were acquired
between 2009 and 2011 in support of the
2010 census to recover Navin address PII
as it's known in the trade for every
record that we were able to recover PII
we call that a putative REE
identification that basically means if
you're an external attacker you would
think that this is the census data
associated with this person's name and
address we then took the complete record
not just the part we used for the
rillette for the reai dent occations act
the complete record name address block
sex age race and ethnicity and compared
it to the truth so that's a confirmed
reai dentition when that happens and the
harm in that experiment is the self
response on race and ethnicity isn't
available in any other database neither
commercial nor governmental that's
entirely internal to the Census Bureau
so you would learn the self response on
race and ethnicity exactly rather than
statistically alright what did we find
well the first thing first thing is
because of the way the publication
tables were constructed it's never any
error in the block ID there's exactly
the right number of records in every
single one of those 6.2 million blocks
and there's never any error and whether
that record is associated with a person
who is not a voting age or a person who
was aged 18 years or older so those are
reconstructed exactly the block sex age
race and ethnicity in the reconstructed
data exactly match 46 percent of the
population in the confidential data on
those five variables so that says that
the image of the confidential data that
you can build outside the firewall has
46 percent of the records exactly right
on those five variables if you allow age
to vary by plus or minus one year then
it has 71 percent or 219 million of the
309 million records
correct well is that salient that's
salient because in the confidential data
on those same five variables more than
50 percent of the records are unique in
the population there's only one record
that looks like that in the whole
population that is the traditional way
of signaling disclosure risk and the
exact percentage is confidential that's
why I've just given you the approved not
even one significant digit but more than
a half so you already know that if the
system was supposed to be designed to
protect against this kind of risk that
it has a vulnerability because you got
46% of them exactly right and in the in
the confidential data in that set of
variables
more than half the records are
population uniques when we did the
putative reaiiy denta fication forty
five percent of those records just using
block sex and age acquired a unique name
and address so that's a 45 percent
putative reaiiy denta fication rate I
think in some literature's that's called
the recall rate the recall rate isn't a
hundred percent the recall rate is 45
percent but that's probably an
underestimate because the denominators
certainly not three hundred and nine
million seven hundred forty five
thousand five hundred thirty-eight
neither the Census Bureau nor any of the
commercial databases now or ever has
full information on the entire
population of the United States even
using consistent rules for what that
might be when we let to confirm those
putative reaiiy dint occations 38
percent of them confirmed so that's 52
million people or seventeen percent of
the population
that confirmation rate is multiple
orders of magnitude bigger than the
largest confirmation rate that the
Census Bureau has ever published for
this kind of study which was based on a
study using the American Community
Survey that was published in 2013 where
the confirmation rate was it's in the
speaker notes I think but I can't see my
speaker notes something like 0.01 7% and
the and the recall rate was 300 odd
cases out of 2.2 million so you can take
my word for it there's not a single
person in the Census Bureau who thought
that either the putative reaiiy denta
fication rate or the confirmation rate
would ever be this high on a relatively
straightforward experiment like this
this just confirms we have already
acknowledged that oh I forgot to read
I'm speaking for myself and not for the
Census Bureau the Census Bureau had
already acknowledged that this was a
vulnerability this just confirmed it in
my view it's basically a waste of time
to keep beating up on these kinds of
experiments to see how bad it might be
in addition to how bad it already is
or as the reporter for the Financial
Times said it results so shocking that
the Commerce Department was brave to
release it I don't know that it was all
that shocking but it was definitely as
far as I'm concerned the nail on the
coffin there does not there's nothing
left to talk about here it's a real
vulnerability it really happened and it
has to be fixed
so that brings me to what I consider to
be the hardest lesson in modern data
science which is a combined implication
of the database reconstruction theorem
and the formally private method of
analyzing systems that are designed to
address it getting your arms around the
information constraint on publication is
really really really really really
really hard and challenging inside an
organization where you have to address
it essentially at every turn there are
branches all over the Census Bureau that
are used to having direct access to the
confidential data we had to find them we
had to identify their methods and we had
to bring them under the privacy laws
budget it really was the death knell for
traditional methods of publication and
I'm not just talking about statistical
agencies it's the figure that I'm sure
you knew I was going to put up I
deliberately don't label the privacy
loss axis in this figure because
everybody in this room knows that this
is algorithmically dependent and the
goal of the computer scientists and the
engineers of these systems is to push
this curve describing the relationship
between privacy loss Epsilon and
accuracy as close to the zero 100% point
as you can like getting an efficient
predictor model and treating this like a
receiver operating characteristics curve
all right but the two extremes no
accuracy and no privacy what the zero
one nature of decision-making in the
past has focused on and we need to learn
how to focus on this frontier to make it
easier to focus on this frontier I
deliberately set it up so that this is
not accuracy from all sources of error
in the data product this is the
incremental loss of accuracy associated
with the disclosure limitations
the privacy protection system so that's
why it's natural as you increase the
privacy loss budget it's going to
asymptote to 100% accuracy
you should engineer that into the
systems if they don't have the property
that when you give the system no
constraints it delivers back the same
answer you would have gotten if you had
skipped the system altogether there's
something wrong with the engineering of
the algorithms but in many cases that
hundred percent accuracy is just as
accurate as the underlying data can't
answer all the question it's not
perfectly accurate answer to the
question so in the case of a census it
ignores the errors associated with
coverage did we get complete coverage in
your geographic area generally speaking
those are measured in terms of net under
counts and differential net under counts
it ignores the errors associated with
the processing of the someplace between
25 and 35 percent of the records that
didn't come from a direct self-response
by the household they came from either
non-response follow-up or they were
incomplete and were finished with other
forms of what we call item allocation
most people just call missing data
imputation now that error is reflected
in that hundred percent accuracy so one
slide of economics it's inefficient to
be inside the frontier you don't want to
use algorithms that deliberately waste
you the privacy lost budget or accuracy
and it's infeasible to be above the
frontier and I might add we don't
actually know where that frontier is
it's very dependent on the set of things
that you want to publish and how you
decide that the accuracy needs to be
assessed
I lied there's two economic slides well
I know how you do it whether you're
there or there and I've eliminated all
of the judgmental labels on this whether
you're there or there that's a social
choice and the tools that we use to make
that social choice don't come from
computer science maybe you don't think
they come from economics either but I
need to understand the willingness to
pay for increased accuracy from forgone
privacy
and that is fundamentally a question
about the Preferences of the population
that you're running the statistics on or
in the case of the census the
preferences of the curators that would
be the Census Bureau over which things
to give accuracy and which things to
give less accuracy to and that's
essentially embodied in those decisions
so we can talk about that but that's
probably not the strong suit I'll take
questions about it we are trying to
collect more data on actual population
preferences and on the Preferences of
the subpopulations that use certain
parts of the of the census publications
in particular data on how accurate data
that are used to draw redistricting have
to be all right
so to address the data based
reconstruction vulnerability for the
2020 census the Census Bureau
implemented differential privacy
effectively at least as far as I can
tell because it was the last thing
standing when you got to the decision
well you've got a vulnerability and you
have to address it what are your
available choices formal privacy models
and from the formal privacy models in
2016 and dan remembers sitting in my
office and us going over whether whether
we what we could actually use
generalizations or whether we should
just stick to the fundamental definition
we decided at that time to stick to the
fundamental definition because that were
there was the most usable stuff out
there for that so we're trying to
demonstrate by actually applying this to
our flagship product again I'm not
speaking for the Census Bureau but I am
using the first-person plural I'm not
quite sure why the intention is to
demonstrate that you can release
statistical data that are fit for their
intended uses and that you can bring an
entire publication system into a formal
privacy loss budget it was a heavy lift
when we set out in 2016 it remains a
heavy lift and here's why there's only
two things that the Constitution and the
statutes require the Census Bureau to
publish from the census the
reapportionment of the House of
Representatives and the file known as PL
94 - 171 redistricting data that data
that we give each state for drawing
legislative districts whose form has
negotiated over the whole decade and
those negotiations were largely complete
in 2016 when the new chief scientists
walked in and suggested that they might
want to consider doing some things a
little bit differently just in the
disclosure avoidance procedure not in
the form of the tables has stayed fixed
what I promised my colleagues at the
Census Bureau was that we would be able
to do those things on time and that that
the data product would be of the quality
that they expect I'll show you the names
of the team the team has delivered that
that's remarkable progress in and of
itself but it doesn't come close to the
rest of what the general user community
expects from a census of population and
you'll hear some talk about summary file
one later today's some even summary file
one turns out to be the tip of the
iceberg when asked to gather all of the
proposed uses of the 2020 census and
then passed them through formal analysis
of how many queries that involved on the
underlying database the number in red on
this slide is to two significant digits
the answer that comes back all right a
hundred billion even I had come nowhere
near doing it informally by looking at
the different table summaries partly
because I hadn't looked past summary
file - to the summary files for American
Indians and Alaska Natives which are
three times as disclosed Avast the
thirty billion queries in summary file -
it's just mathematically impossible to
do that with the level of accuracy that
has previously been used with a finite
privacy lost budget I think the team put
it at someplace between 45 and a hundred
an epsilon that might address a
substantial subset of these with
accuracy similar to the way they had
been published in 2010 so that's a huge
challenge so here's my kudos to the team
they've done a lot of work I'm gonna
show you some of it in a second we've
got methods for quantifying and
displaying system-wide trade-offs
between accuracy and privacy loss and
between the allocation of accuracy to
one set of tables and a versus another
set of tables it started in 2016 so we
are slightly more than two years into it
in my view that was a monumental
achievement but it doesn't come close to
meeting the concerns of the user
community we'll have some time to talk
about that but let me just show you what
what you can do right Dan Kiefer in his
talk I think he's the next one it's
gonna take you through the technical
issues here one of them is that some
people think that some numbers have to
be published without disclosure
avoidance error I will just say that
there is no legal justification for that
statement because Utah v Evans the 2002
case the last time somebody from the
Census Bureau appeared in testimony that
was that got to the Supreme Court that
case determined that the Census Bureau
is allowed to use accepted statistical
methods in preparing its publications it
was about County mutation if you don't
what count imputation is at the very end
of the process of counting for every
address in the United States that during
the census there are some addresses left
over they haven't been accounted for we
don't know if there are fake fakes not
the right word they don't know if they
should have been deleted from our
address list or if they're vacant or if
they're occupied so they go through a
statistical model now
at one point one six million people in
2010 were put into the census and not
all in the same state or in equal
proportions across the states by that
process so not even the numbers that go
into reapportionment have to be
published quote exactly as enumerated
however that is the kind of policy
discussion that takes a long time to
have so this chart shows you what
happens when you set the state
population as an invariant meaning
there's no differential privacy noise in
a single number these experiments were
done on the state of Rhode Island using
its 2010 data so in each case they only
invariant and these figures is the state
population I forget what it is in Rhode
Island but it doesn't matter you can
look it up it was a public number they
had no disclosure avoidance noise in in
2010 either the accuracy measure is take
all the tables in the redistricting data
at the particular level of geography
here state county tract or block take
all of them calculate the total
variation distance between that table
and the truth average it over all the
tables in the workload and subtract that
number from one so this may not help you
guys but it helps many statistical
audiences the total variation average
total variation distance is like the
percentage of entries in the table that
would have to be flipped in order to get
back to the true table so when the
accuracy is a hundred percent it means
that the protected table is essentially
identical to the true table I'll show
you in a second one of these things
organized with privacy loss on the
x-axis and accuracy on the y-axis but
this this set of slides is designed to
show you on the x-axis
over at zero all of the privacy lost
budget is assigned to the redistricting
data and over at one all the privacy
lost budget is assigned to the flagship
counterpart in summary file one which is
the age by six tables so the
redistricting data are detailed data on
race and ethnicity and the only age
variable to have them where your voting
age or not and the sex by age tables are
detailed data on the population pyramid
in each of those geographies sex by age
so the first thing you can see is those
tables are highly correlated and as a
consequence at the state level it makes
almost no difference I don't even need
to tell you what the values of epsilon
are on each of those curves or what the
table sets reflected by the time you get
up to a state the size of Rhode Island
there's essentially no loss of accuracy
except a pointer on this yes except out
here just this slide doesn't project
very well does it out here my slides are
public and I will be happy to send them
to anyone and you're free to
redistribute them you can also see that
it really doesn't matter for the five
counties in in Rhode Island essentially
where you set that privacy loss budget
where they put it all on the
redistricting data or you put it all on
the summary file data doesn't matter it
starts to matter at the level of a tract
tract has approximately 4,000 people in
it so these tracks
it matters you see if I can remember all
the scales here again I'm having trouble
reading my speaker notes
all right so the red lines are the
summary file one the age and sex
pyramids okay
and the black lines are the
redistricting data so if all of the
values of epsilon are stacked on top of
each other here so it doesn't really
matter which is which even at the track
level there's a lot more cells in this
sex by age table then in the
redistricting once so if you don't give
them any of the privacy lost budget all
of this accuracy is due to those
correlations with the redistricting data
but even if you give them all the
accuracy at the track level for some
values of epsilon each of these curves
is for a separate value of epsilon
starting at 0.25 I believe yes
so that's 0.25 the highest one is ten
ten is coincident with this this is
three so
the key thing here is all of these
redistricting ones are pinned up against
the accuracy of one most voting
districts are quite a bit bigger than a
tract so this says that the allocation
of the privacy loss in the top-down
algorithm that Dan's going to explain to
you essentially delivers data that are
as accurate as you could hope for as
long as the population inside the voting
district is bigger than a track now that
statement is qualified and he'll spend a
lot more time on this by the fact that
voting districts aren't coincident with
tract borders however these county and
state boundaries and many of these tract
boundaries are coincident with the
boundaries of voting districts because
of the way they're constructed and so if
you build the accuracy hierarchy n on a
fixed geographic hierarchy elect block
traffic county and state that also
constrains the arbitrary voting
districts they're going to inherit some
of the accuracy and I didn't bring any
of these tables with me because they
haven't been graphed up and released but
that is that statement is true so
finally you get to the block level and
you can see that for the age pyramids
it's hard to get accuracy that it gets
anywhere near one for the redistricting
data you have to use very large privacy
loss budgets to get an accuracy anywhere
near one and the one you can't see the
gray one is the population table which
is here
it's the ones coming off here there's
also noise in the population levels so
you need to and that's correlated with
both the pl 94 and sf1 tables so what do
we do now I've taken the same
assumptions and plotted this out with
the privacy loss on the horizontal axis
and the accuracy on the vertical axis
this is the block level accuracy
to get the block level accuracy anywhere
near a hundred percent you have to give
that whole operation a fairly large
privacy loss budget but if you look it
starts to bend in here and in fact we
set the privacy loss budget they're not
quite where it is on the array coming
out of the origin we set it there point
two five because as soon as you get to
the tract level its 0.98 as soon as you
get to the county and state level it's
essentially a hundred percent if the use
case is for populations geographic areas
their populations that are resemble a
tract this is more accurate than the
data that was used in 2010 on some
criteria less accurate on others but
certainly comparable you don't need
accurate block level data to build
arbitrary districts you need accurate
data that aggregate properly as you
build up these arbitrary shapes and
those arbitrary shapes need to be
plausibly constrained by whether they're
obviously contained by block that's the
pixel you can't use anything but a block
many of the boundaries of constrained by
tract almost all political boundaries
are constrained by counties and and
states so the use case fits and there's
no reason to go out here to three to get
the block data accurate and there's very
good reasons not to
and I spent most of the last year on
seven days in testimony discussing the
very good reason not to go out here for
the block level data it's one of the
variables into 2020 is likely to be
citizenship water the top two or three
cases for which somebody would argue for
flat level statistics use cases don't
want you do my rest of my slides yeah I
said I'd take questions so so the use
case for the sex by age pyramids is
state county and city demographers
building population models predicting
the number of school-age children and
other the sizes of the retired
communities and and other things that
are strongly correlated with public
services and in our collection of use
cases those are almost always done at
political boundaries the least dense
political boundary that the Census
Bureau routinely publishes data for is
called a place or minor civil division
in some states the minor civil division
substitutes for counties but in most
states the minor civil divisions are
subsets of counties they generally
respect the county or County equivalent
orders but they don't respect tract
borders so if you if you look at a
standard census geographic hierarchy
they're built on blocks they bypass the
tract and they go straight to the county
in that hierarchy okay there's about
15,000 of them which is still not a huge
number of of places but the population
estimates program has agreed to design
differentially private publications for
minor civil divisions and places in
exchange for being granted direct access
to the 2020 census in the years between
2020 and 2030 so they still haven't
given their privacy lost budget but that
there they're working and that's the
best use case that I know
so as Jerome's question alluded to this
is just the tip of the iceberg probably
the most used product from a census that
is not statutorily dictated as what we
have called the demographic profiles
they are summaries that have
traditionally been built by taking all
the tables in summary file one and
aggregating them to that minor civil
division place level and then viewing
statistical summaries of them we can
handle almost all of the workload from
the demographic profiles for persons and
for households I'll get to the query
that we can't do in a second and answer
them with a reasonable privacy loss
budget so that's nice
but exactly what privacy lost budget
should we use for the ensemble of the
products should we go out to epsilon of
8.9 I can pick on that number because
that's the epsilon and on the map that
multiple people in the room participated
in engineering in 2008 so that's a big
epsilon that the Census Bureau used
starting in 2008 and still the epsilon
and that product how do you go about
inside an agency saying okay build the
use case for your users then if you go
outside the agency outside the agency I
think you may have heard some good
examples of this last week the answer to
the question is how how you should
allocate the privacy lost budget is you
should make my project perfect and let
the rest of the people deal with the
noise and I wish I were making that
answer up so that's not feasible the
statute is silent on granting any other
curators the authority to manage the
privacy loss budget so it's going to
have to be done by the senior executives
at the Census Bureau it's done in the
data stewardship executive policy
committee which consists entirely of
career civil servants and is chaired by
the deputy director and chief operating
officer currently around Jarman so
that's the answer to how we're going to
deal with the privacy loss policy
managing the invariance is a really hard
problem we'll probably have more
discussion of that after Dan shows you
just how hard it was to engineer the
ability to have invariance into the
system but in addition the researchers
on the Census team did the original
mathematics for what it means to have
invariance in one of these publication
systems they were outside the scope of
the differential privacy literature so
the mathematical definition is that you
that your publication system has two
algorithms operating on it one of them
gives exact answers and the other one
gives differentially private answers
constrained to have the exact answers be
true so one
you set that problem up you want to know
how much to blame on the invariance and
how much to blame on the
privacy-preserving
publication system that was a hard
question to answer and it has a very
unsatisfying answer if you're trying to
manage policy the presence of invariance
implies because it's a violation of the
fundamental theorem of information
recovery implies that there are some
situations for which there's infinite
privacy loss and it's relatively easy if
you're in trained in the cryptographic
tradition to find those cases so you can
see what it is but invariance come from
either real policy or interpretation of
policy and they're not going to go away
just because most of the people in this
room say your system shouldn't have
invariance they inherently leak an
infinite amount of information under
certain circumstances and you're trying
to design the systems to contain those
circumstances to not make assumptions
about the attackers information set so
there isn't an obvious way to quantify
what happens when you put invariance in
the system but there are some
mathematical approaches that I think
would be useful they are built on the
following intuition Bob the differential
privacy admits one invariant you the
number of records in the database is
public and it's pretty well understand
understood what that does to the
semantics of of the differentially
private remaining publications
having 50 state population invariants
technically 51 but Washington DC doesn't
actually go into the redistricting the
reapportionment algorithm having 51
State population invariants there must
be some sense in which there are more
states of the world that that allows
information leakage for then when
there's only one similarly having 11
million block level population
invariants there must be more states of
the world in which that allows infinite
information leakage then with 50 so some
of the team are trying to make those
statements precise because I don't want
to go to the data stewardship executive
policy committee and say we have to
consider how to do reapportionment in
the presence of differential privacy and
not have real mathematics underlying
that decision basically owe it to
successor policymaking groups at the
Census Bureau to not use these kinds of
arguments anymore but that's a really
hard argument I don't know how to do
externally reviewable quantification but
not in the sense of the differential
privacy quantification of what it means
to either have a statutorily imposed
invariant or to act as if you had one
and I will remind you that there is no
statute that says or judicial
interpretation that says that the state
populations should be exempted from the
confidentiality protection system that's
hard question the the self responses and
internally edited versions of the census
I said that very carefully because it
excludes anything that came in from
administrative records become public 72
years after the census and so you would
like the privacy lost budget to decay
naturally over that 72 year period I
think that might actually be one that
can be reasonably thought about one of
the prime claimants to the privacy lost
budget over the first decade is the
population estimates program which
reuses the data from the
from census so that it can combine it
with with data from other sources to get
estimates of the change in the
population in each of those 15,000 minor
civil divisions and places we manage the
access of external researchers to the
census there is the perception that you
just go into the RDC and you get granted
access to historical censuses that's
actually not true when you go into the
RDC you'll get granted access to a
particular variant of the historical
census that at least in principle was
designed to have privacy protections in
it so the principle about what you use
in the restricted access environment has
privacy protections and is already
built-in nevertheless I think it's now
incumbent on researchers who want to use
the confidential versions of the 2020
census to include in their proposal the
differentially private analysis system
that they propose to use that's gonna
have to get peer-reviewed because it's
really really easy not to get that right
spoken from someone who has been down
that rabbit hole many times it's also
really easy not to program it right so
we need to figure out how to ensure that
it was properly implemented and finally
that means we're gonna have to queue
those up
now the data stewardship executive
policy committee is gonna have to decide
how much if any Epsilon each one gets
and add that to our accumulated privacy
lost budget to say that we haven't set
that system up yet would be to basically
state the obvious so we set that up for
external users does the same thing apply
to internal users I think the answer to
that question has to be yes so anyway I
wanted my last slide I wanted to
acknowledge I think that this is a
reasonably complete list of the major
contributors to the work that has been
done inside the Census Bureau some of
them are computer scientists
statisticians sitting in this room
others are full-time since its employees
some come from the subject matter areas
some come from the statistical areas I
don't know whether to think of this as a
big team or a large team it has borne
the brunt of the last two and a half
years worth of work and
I have mostly been summarizing the
really great work that they did my
slides include some links to some of the
things that I have talked about in our
implementation see I have a date wrong
on that last one I might fix that that
was December 6th of twenty twenty twenty
twenty nineteen yeah that that error
escaped Minnie proofreaders alright I'll
take questions to the speaker to leave
plenty of time for questions so we have
15 minutes one thing I want to address
before taking question is that we will
have two panel one tomorrow and one on
Thursday the one of tomorrow will be on
now to set in the privacy budget so it
was related to some of the question with
solder in John thoughts and the one on
Thursday will be on where statistical
agency going yeah so can you speak some
to the benefits of disclosing the
techniques for fighting noise yes and
kind of to give you like this solid poll
question
I remember a debacle from a few years
ago where it was discovered that the
microdata like messed up badly the data
for seniors senior citizens and it's
less likely to happen for for the
methods that you are advocating so
Kanaka tell us what to it is done on
that site do you want the history of the
debacle which sounds like something that
Steve Ruggles told you about last week
or do you want what we're doing about it
for both okay
so among the ad-hoc systems that are
used to protect confidentiality in all
of our current
Alex are some algorithms that add noise
to selected variables inside the micro
data before they're passed the
tabulation or before they are released
as a part of a public use micro sample
it was documented that the algorithms
that were used for the original 2000
census public use micro sample and the
public used micro samples from the
American Community Survey until the
middle of the 2000s I forget the exact
year that the problem problem was
discovered and published in 2010 by
researchers working at the Minnesota
population center that's Steve Ruggles
Institute what they did was they
compared what would now seem like a
pretty obvious mistake but they compared
the tabular summaries which had not been
passed through the same disclosure
limitation methods to the things that
came out of the micro data
assessing the incremental noise that was
added to the micro data and the age
profiles the sex age profiles for people
aged 65 and older were all wacky because
of a programming error in the disclosure
limitation which would probably not have
been exposed if they hadn't done it two
ways there's a lot of more discussion of
that in my paper with Ian in that which
appeared in an economics journal where
it would do the users some good but not
the computer scientists the Brookings
papers on economic activity so what
we're doing for the formerly private
2020 census is first of all we're making
all the algorithms public so that you
can see exactly where the noise was
infused we have prepared a special
extract from the 1940 census which is
public that's being curated by the pubs
again
Ruggles Institute so that it doesn't get
revised when they they they routinely
improve their historical data assets so
this one won't be revised as the same
inputs when we release the code base for
the what we did for the 2018 end-to-end
test there will be a wrapper that loads
a comparable extract it's not on cases
but on very
ables of that 1940 PUMS so that you can
play with it you can change the privacy
laws budget you can change allocation
assumptions in that privacy less budget
it doesn't do the full set of tables it
only does the redistricting tables but
we are trying to help the user community
understand where the where the noise
comes from and what its consequences are
we're also going to release some number
of runs from the data that underlie this
chart so that you can do redistricting
plans on them and see the the intrinsic
variability good enough
I guess a couple of questions so one you
know one in in addition to providing the
code are you thinking of providing any
kind of more easily interpretable
evaluation of error like you know error
bars or things like you wouldn't be
publishing the tables so so thanks for
that question the answer is that I want
to publish something that looks like
error bars and that is an open
discussion what we've committed to is to
the extent that the algorithms require
additional calculations in order for
those error bars to be computable
outside the firewall we will devote
privacy lost budget to that so there's
some data dependence and the algorithms
you'll see when when Dan goes through
them that there's some data dependence
that's unavoidable and so you can't just
take epsilon and simulate it from our
software you need to know a few bias
correction terms that we think we know
how to calculate so we if we can't do it
I have no doubt that an outside value
added resupply err will do it my guess
is that exactly two will do it and they
will have red and blue labels on them
but I did say that with the camera on I
hope that's interpreted in the spirit
that it was meant you know that the
point of open access to the code is not
to have people pat you on the back it's
basically they have people upon your
mistakes and competitive use of of the
of the programs is going to do that a
whole lot better than me sending them
through many rounds of Correction inside
the bureau I'll let you follow up if you
have a sense of how those errors that
you plot it in the table that's on the
slide there those total variation
distance errors like how they're
distributed across different you know
tracks or or blocks I
in relative terms they said to
concentrate in the smaller so virtually
everything you want to know you see in
summary statistics that are stratified
by the estimated population size you
know whatever the geographic area is I
didn't bring any of those with me but we
have certainly looked at those and
that's the right way to think about it I
think this this algorithm was tuned so
that the accuracy improved as the
population and the geographic unit
increased in and so that the main things
you want to look at the error of are
there these charts here actually show
you how the air has been allocated
between the sexes by age table and the
racial ethnicity tables so there's
already some some things you can learn
like the sex by age tables are at the
block level are intrinsically harder to
get more accurate it's a paper workload
rocker fascinating and tremendous amount
of work on me every time I hear this and
like whoa just so few people so much
wood but one thing is very naive
question that this sort of you have no
good to be in the past but I'm sure you
got before so these 38% in there
I was wondering if I not knowing any
census data not having access to them if
I were to take the exome data or
somewhere that I can purchase as we
often do in the survey accounts right
and with trying to predict race and
ethnicity how intimate this is a small
number of bakeries huh how good would
but what's the probability of getting it
right so one of the assessments were
doing of the reconstruction is what kind
of statistics can you compute from the
reconstructed micro data that would be
predictive of your ability to either
putative leary identify or confirmed
reaiiy denta phi so we're looking at
population uniqueness statistics and the
other side of that homophily statistics
that you can compute once you've
reconstructed the data constructing the
right counterfactual for the information
gain is trickier because basically
you've already demonstrated that the
block level tables were to disclose 'iv
so saying that you don't get much of an
information gain over the already to
disclose of block level tables is just
repeating the charge
what's my what's my that's right so
what's the appropriate counterfactual
for the information I'd be able to learn
in the absence of the block level tables
and I don't know the American Community
Survey tables they might have the same
problem
instances when people have to report
their racing so the commercial so to
keep the exercise fair we used
commercial data from 2009 to 2011
there's almost no race and ethnicity
data in those so it is a and every one
of those companies that had that
variable in there said it was modeled
which doesn't surprise me no I'm
guessing I even know what it was
modelled on but I'm not going to go
there
so it is really hard to construct it the
counterfactual that's a reasonable
summary of what you could have learned
if we hadn't published these enormous ly
disclosed of tables in the first place
we need to keep on trying because there
are people that's your job so maybe yes
to the people the coffee break
[Applause]